بدات روسيا وكانها ترتدي ستره واقيه من
الرصاص رصاص العقوبات التي انهالت عليها
من امريكا والغرب منذ اكثر من تسعه اشهر
وتحسنت بمكاسب اقتصاديه حرمتها من اي
ازمات حاده فوفقا لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز لا
تزال روسيا مندمجه بشده داخل منظومه
العالمي وهي حقيقه قاسيه لا تستطيع حتى
الدول الغربيه انكارها
والوقائع تتحدث
وللمفارقه فقد زادت قيمه الصادرات الروسيه
بعد الحرب والارقام هنا تتحدث ايضا
فصادرات روسيا الى بلجيكا ارتفعت قيمتها
الشهريه بنسبه مذهله بلغت 130 في المئه
والى اسبانيا بنسبه 112%
وهولاندا بنسبه 74
100 كما ارتفعت الصادرات الشهريه الى
المانيا بنسبه
38% اذا فدول الغربيه التي حاولت جاهده
ترتيب حزمي العقوبات تلوى العقوبات على
روسيا تدرك جيدا انها لا تستطيع العيش
بدون موادها الخام وخاصه النفط والغاز
فرضت اوروبا والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
عقوبات على الاوريجارشيه الروسيه
وتوقفت عن ارسال التكنولوجيا المتقدمه الى
روسيا كما حظرت جميع الرحلات الجويه
القادمه من الدول التي يفترض انها معزوله
لكن فيما يتعلق بقطاع النفط والغاز لم
تملك الا ان تبدا الحركه بل توقف الاندفاع
ومع كل خساره بدا ان روسيا تتعرض لها كانت
تجد دائما
واسعار النفط والغاز المرتفعه صبت على نحو
مثير السخريه في الخزانه الروسيه وقد سجلت
شركه غاز بروم عملاق الطاقه الروسيه الذي
تديره الدوله ارباحا قياسيا بلغت 41
مليارا و 300 مليون دولار على المستوى
التجاري
وبينما خفضت الدول المعاديه شحناتها الى
روسيا نهض الدول مثل الصين وتركيا وايران
وغيرها لتعويض الفجوه ويتسائل المحللون هل
نجحت العقوبات في التاثير على بوتن او حتى
قصرت من امد الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ام
ان الدول التي عاقبت الرئيس الروسي قد
ارتد اليها نصيب من هذا العقاب